what's up everybody brian scalabrine
former nba player current
nba analyst here to help you with your
picks
this tournament yeah and i'm gonna be
here too your cousin
from boston and i'm also gonna give you
a bunch of advice from me and and the
white mambo
mom bob right
so the first thing that i look for
obviously you want to have
a couple upperclassmen couple seniors on
a team couple of juniors on the team
those are the ones that will advance
keep the basketball going in the right
direction
why do they cut these nets is that for
the sea turtles
no it's a celebration it's like
memorabilia all i'm saying is if i'm
swimming around
in the ocean and this thing ends up on
my head i'm in trouble
let's talk about upsets the seeds you
gotta look at 10
11 12. they might have had a bad loss
late in the year and people are
overreacting yeah and i'm noticing that
there's like a trend of like those short
shorts coming back you have any comment
on that i know you used to
wear short shorts you know whether i
wear short shorts or long shorts it
actually didn't make a difference when i
was on the court
with oh it's good
speaking of court stories i was once on
a courtroom tv show called boston's
dumbest defense we're talking about real
analyst work here very interesting
tournament all the games in one location
everybody watching every team play so
you're really going to have to study him
yeah you don't get the leverage you need
why are you
you can't just show up if you don't care
i've been showing up and not caring my
whole life
hey pete check it out i know you got no
plans i got the tv set up you come over
we'll watch some games oh my gosh yeah
i can't wait yeah i'll call you oh you
got my number
it's yup i got it it's fine i got it i
got it i got it i got it
ma the white mambo is coming over
the white mambo brian scalabrine